Dr Gray I'm I'm so sorry I know this is
hard but you gotta keep a safe distance
all right okay Meredith's house goes up
in flames on the Gray's anatomy's
mid-season finale is she the most cursed
television character that has ever lived
basically I mean I guess you know
um Hey listen it's drama yeah we need
drama and the drama was there on
Thursday's episode as Ellen's Meredith
comes home to her house on fire
it's our house man all right let it
through all right it's okay everyone's
fine the kids are right here what
happened oh my God
we were upstairs and lightning struck
the house we got the kids we came down
got outside as quickly as we could we
wanted to go back in and take some boxes
but the fire it's okay you're okay
that's all I care about the one item
that made it through the destruction the
Post-it note on which Meredith and her
late husband Derek Shepard got married
all those years ago this is our wedding
I post it
um
you sign it that one
now I guess the bride
Winston's I missed earlier
that's how when the lightning hit it it
was all I managed to take where all
storms inside
[Music]
and it's no surprise that a lot went
down when ETI spoke to Ellen's co-star
Camilla Luddington ahead of the episode
she offered this warning I think the
general rule should always be that if we
have an
it should just be an automatic weeks out
like call out sex take Friday off yeah
100 always in the preview for Gray's
return on February 23rd Meredith walks
the halls of gray Sloan on her last day
preparing to leave Seattle behind it's
been a lot of Fire
[Music]
this is very thoughtful and ridiculous
God Saves gravy you just let us toast
you
trying to reinvent the show is the
challenge at this point and you know
listen the show speaks to a lot of
people and the young people love the
show it's inspired so many generations
of healthcare workers so I think for for
the young people it's a really good
piece of content and we're going to try
to keep it going for the young people
not necessarily with me but you know to
keep it going Beyond me and though
Meredith is beginning a new chapter on
the East Coast this won't be the last
time viewers see her Ellen is set to
appear in Eight Episodes this season the
winter Premiere marks her seventh
meaning the actress will return to Grace
at least one more time before season 19
is over it's still Grace she's still
there in spirit and that's the house
that gray built so she's always there
looming
foreign